two Cuban migrants fly into Florida on a
motorized hang glider two migrants used
a motorized hang glider to fly 90 miles
from the Communist island of Cuba to Key
West and they landed safely at Key West
International Airport at about 10 30 a.m
I think those guys should stay I want to
hire those guys I don't even know I
don't know what they would do around
here they can they can start Jeremy's
Jeremy's airplanes I
Jeremy's hang gliders I just think if
you have the guts and the Ingenuity to
get a single person light hang glider
that's supposed to go you know jumping
from puddle to puddle you take that and
you fly 90 miles across shark infested
waters to Florida and then land safely
at the airport I want you